Another implication is that you should not use assertions to check for public preconditions
that is, conditions that your program must check anyway
to ensure the integrity of data coming from third parties.
As an example, if you have, say website or device, myaccount.com,
where users can enter arbitrary amounts of data to be processed
then do not use an assertion to check for the integrity of this data
instead use a check that is not optional and will always remain active.
So, in our example over here, here's something that you should not write.
So here, we get an input, convert this into an integer, store this in deposit,
and then we use an assert to check this external data
to make sure the deposit is greater or equal than 0.
As soon as I turned the assertion off, this check will no longer be performed,
and therefore, it would be possible, say, to enter negative deposit numbers.
What you should do instead is just a regular check.
If you do have some invalid data in here that comes from a third party, raise an exception,
abort execution, pop up an error message
or do whatever is most appropriate for the situation.